it's the fourth cabinet in seven months
the government awaits congressional
approval on tuesday but it won't be easy
some lawmakers say they will not give
the new ministers a vote of confidence
unless prime minister aniwa torres makes
changes
[Music]
starting with firing the new health
minister hernan condori a doctor accused
of corruption and lack of experience
that has doctors and nurses demanding
his resignation and some of president
pedro castillo's ministers and closer
circle of advisers are being
investigated for corruption
given the accumulation of allegations
for the moral health of the republic the
president should come to congress to
answer our questions about all this
castillo himself is being investigated
since january for corruption and illegal
influence the president denies any
wrongdoing
they lie in the media saying he's
already going to resign he's corrupt i'm
not going to run away because a tiny
group of people wants to disregard the
will of the people who've put me in
office
[Music]
hours before tuesday's session his
allies had been unable to secure enough
votes for the new cabinet
i am afraid that peruvian politics
rather than seeking consensus is
dominated by short-term calculations
linked to immediate interests
many say the opposition's most pressing
interest now is paving the way for a new
ballgame
whether congress approves the new
cabinet or not critics say the real
endgame for opposition lawmakers is to
oust president castillo
a motion to unseat the president is in
the works it's the second time political
foes tried to impeach castillo but
analysts say they still don't have
enough votes to begin the process
that doesn't mean this is the end we
will surely see discussions on how to
eventually push for the president's
removal from office
a recent opinion poll suggests more than
60 percent disapprove of castillo and 77
percent disapprove of congress
from crisis to crisis the spiraling
political chaos has left the country
with five precedents in six years nearly
30 ministers were placed since last
august
disenchanted with peru's political class
for most peruvians tuesday's vote may
not make much of a difference mariana
sanchez al jazeera lima peru